you may not have noticed these white
boxes mounted on poles across Seattle
when I'm walking downtown I look up and
I see these things that weren't there
before it's designed to keep our
community safe and just to be part of
effective government do you know what
these white boxes are on street corners
in Seattle Washington for a long time
residents didn't even know it's a Wi-Fi
network set up to help the Seattle
Police Department and several other city
agencies fight crime terrorism and cope
with major disasters but some say those
boxes are capable of something else
tracking your location we're a great
Police Department we want to make sure
we're doing everything we can to keep
the community safe part of that is using
technology to our advantage to make our
jobs easier to make our investigations
more successful but Sergeant John
Whitcomb of the Seattle Police
Department he agreed to talk with us
about Seattle's mesh network Wi-Fi
system that is a part of a 2.7 million
dollar grant from the Federal Emergency
Management Agency that's a part of the
Department of Homeland Security this is
the port security grant it's got two
major components one is a camera
component and one is a wireless mesh or
Wi-Fi component they're integrated and
it goes all along the Seattle coastline
in Seattle's case the network would
provide communication between law
enforcement Fire Department medical
services and Coast Guard personnel in
case of a disaster when a traditional
wireless network may be broken
ultimately it's designed to keep our
community safe to help out with criminal
investigations and just to be part of
effective government it seemed like a
great plan to improve public safety
until citizens began to see this curious
Network pop up on their phones as an
available Wi-Fi network to connect to
people started to realize oh when I'm
walking downtown I look up and I see
these things that weren't there before
on the polls I'm opening up my cell
phone and I'm looking at available Wi-Fi
networks and the corner appears to be an
available Wi-Fi network the intersection
and that's strange and it wasn't there
before
and it started to raise a lot of
questions that's Brian robic senior
policy strategist at the American Civil
Liberties Union of Washington the
problem is is that these national
networks can have capabilities that
citizens wouldn't necessarily want to
have including the ability to track
devices that pass
through the blanket via network coverage
so here's how these wireless access
points could be tracking you if you go
into your phone's Wi-Fi settings you'll
see these networks named after
intersections third and union fourth and
pike fourth and Union these are all on
the mesh network here's how that
location tracking might work the Wi-Fi
network wouldn't just be able to know
which grocery store bar you frequent but
also which doctor's office you visit if
you frequented a gun shop or went to an
abortion clinic piecing together things
you might not want people to know about
the concern from the public was big
enough that the Seattle PD ended up
shutting down the network in November
2013 and since those concerns were
raised by the community we have been
working with the community and city
council and mayor's office to develop a
policy that will address privacy
concerns while still allowing us to use
this technology but it's been nine
months and still no set of rules have
been solidified so the boxes are just
sitting there going unused until the
Seattle PD can figure out protocols
protocols would give the Seattle Police
the opportunity to show how they are
going to use surveillance technology to
protect people and show how they're
going to protect their their their
privacy aruba networks the manufacturer
of Seattle's system told us that the
Wi-Fi they provided to the city is not
designed to track users but robic says
software updates could change this fact
in the future and without a
crystal-clear privacy policy for how the
network is to be used citizens don't
have any reassurances that their privacy
is being protected the City Council has
asked that every single time you add
something or change something that the
police disclose it and we're still
waiting for them to disclose what
they're gonna do at the baseline but
without that we have no assurance of
what they're going to add on to the
network to change it to do other things
robic also says that one of the most
troubling parts of the city's process
for acquiring this mesh network and
surveillance camera system was how it
was detailed in the city's request for
proposals in 2012 their initial proposal
was to give the Washington State fusion
center a direct connection into
essentially a DVR of the recordings
the cameras the Washington State fusion
center tries to stop major crime two
terrorist acts by collecting and
analyzing massive amounts of data
submitted by local law enforcement
agencies like the Seattle PD and federal
agencies like DHS and the FBI it was
very clear in their request for
proposals that that was the initial
intention take a look at diagram
submitted in the city of Seattle's
proposal in 2012 you can see how
interconnected the mesh network and
camera system is going to be that has
been a surprising bit of information to
some of the folks that we have spoken
the lymph idiom in the police department
when we bring it up and I don't believe
that that's their intention to have the
connection anymore but do you think it's
interesting that when cities are
campaigning for grants that they build
in additional information sharing and in
a way barter the people's privacy in
order to get the funds that they need to
put up these systems people have a
reasonable expectation to live their
lives without feeling that the
government is constantly tracking them
or constantly looking at them and
learning about what they think do and
believe in and we shouldn't have to
trade that that Liberty for security
technology has changed how we interact
with each other we just need to make
sure that as we move forward there are
some safeguards and protections in place
that allow us to operate efficiently and
legally while still maintaining that
sense of privacy that people deserve and
expect in our society but remember the
city has gone nine months without that
finalized privacy policy and in a world
where police are acquiring new
technology every day that can invade a
citizens privacy rules for data
collection data sharing and guidelines
for the future may be the only
assurances law enforcement can protect
us and protect our civil liberties at
the same time for recent TV i'm paul
dietrich